[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you had a
wonderful week thanks for listening um
if you're in your drive
uh this is a a great episode um
really enjoyed this guy lamorne morris
you know from new girl uh new show woke
talks about second city ryan it was a
really fun episode this guy is
incredibly funny he's really really
quick he's really quick it was
intimidating how quick he was i liked it
i loved him uh that's coming up in just
a second um hey if you're listening to
the podcast or if you're here for the
morning i hope you stick around i hope
you uh subscribe to the podcast you can
watch on youtube you can listen uh
anywhere you listen to podcasts the
handles ryan uh at insideablypod on
twitter inside to be podcast on
instagram facebook yeah um jeff good
week man i've been uh i've been anxious
i feel like i'm overwhelmed about
everything i'm learning we talked about
this before the show and uh i'm just uh
you know it's it's one of those things
where i just have to be more positive
going into things yeah
yeah
you're allowed to have feelings but you
know try to keep the positive vibes
going the world has not fixed itself and
uh you just kind of have to we have to
find a way to live in it now yeah so hey
if you're having anxiety or anything
like that this week uh i hope you uh
breathe and do something productive and
exercise uh i'm trying to do that so
that's helping but uh trying to keep the
anxiety in check that's a that's always
a tough thing to do but you could do it
um hey if you want to buy any merch
inside of you online store tons of stuff
on there uh tons of small little stuff
and lex luthor stuff and all that [ __ ]
uh go to the inside of you online store
if you want to buy any band stuff or
zoom with me go to sunspin.com
um
tons of merch and all that stuff and if
you want to join patreon the lovely
patron family
um go to patreon.com inside of you and
it's to give to the podcast a little
more and help us out and uh
i'll message you after there's a lot of
great perks
and all that stuff so uh i thank you all
for listening to the podcast and uh
yeah life's all right man life's good
we're alive we're breathing we're
[ __ ] here we're here dude let's do it
let's get inside of the wonderful
lamourne morris it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you come across as an educated just like
articulate
guy who's got his [ __ ] together is that
true or is it lamorn or is it is that
false
it's it's you know it's a little from
column a little from columbia
i uh i like to play when i can um but at
the same time
you know i think it's important to to be
an adult i have a daughter now you know
and it's like
hey i'm responsible
she will survive me how do you do that
though how do you how do you balance
that having a kid and working so much
because you're always working you're
always doing stuff how how do you do
that because you know the probably the
biggest fear you have is like am i going
to be a bad father am i not going to be
around enough it might not get right is
that a fear it is a fear because well
she's 11 months old and i've been
co-parenting so the reason the way i
balance it is that baby mama does a lot
of the lifting you know what i mean so
she's she's with her full time and i see
her once a month i go there
you know i stay i get a place in austin
and then or she'll come here to la so
it's a lot of traveling back and forth
or if i'm out filming somewhere like in
atlanta she comes to atlanta with me you
know things like that you know you get
the timing when you can um
so
you make it work you you make it work
does she like being outside
does she like being on set does she like
seeing daddy work
well because of kovac can't be on set
you know what i mean it's just
off you know after work you know what i
mean it's kind of
it's been a it's been a treat with
covert on set you know well you're you
you're one of those guys though i i
gather
that just has to be busy all the time
that just like i mean even during covet
that was an excuse for me to do jack
[ __ ] and no one could say anything about
it but for you you ended up doing this
like
series
yeah i mean i mean who does that who
does a series during kova that you
create
yeah it's weird it was uh
it because we had started the process
before covent you know what i mean we
shot the pilot and kova didn't really
start booming until we were almost done
recording season one
you know and so we got the green light
for season two during the middle of all
the chaos and craziness
um
and with all the restrictions and and
things on set we everybody felt like it
was um
okay and safe to to get back to work and
and for the most part it has been we've
had no crazy incidents we've had some
shutdowns right but it's not been no
one's no one's died no one's gotten
really sick
it's just been you know we get a case we
shut down
someone it doesn't matter which
department they're in you shut down for
a little bit until you contact trace and
do all that stuff so it's not been bad
it's not been hard to do right um
but for me i've always just wanted to
remain active you know what i mean and
i've gotten lucky i got very very lucky
to to get some stuff greenlit do you
like being in charge do you like having
projects that are your projects that you
have a say that you're a producer on is
that what the direction you'd rather go
than being i hate to say a puppet but
like coming on set and like you know
what do you prefer
oh absolutely absolutely i would love
like being in charge is great you know
what i mean especially
especially if you think you have better
ideas you know um but no with especially
with this show you know i'm a producer
on the show
but
i didn't create the show though i didn't
create this show
or a producer on the show but i do have
some say and the rest of the producers
and the creators are very collaborative
they they're not like
they're not like this is our way or the
highway you know i get the scripts we
take notes we make changes
um that i think that's important
especially being a producer is to be
able to collab with the people who are
smarter than you in those areas always i
am and ultimately i want to be adam
sandler man like i
i won can i be your david spade could i
be your nick schwartzen can i just be
like
please just have me come aboard somehow
please do man like i told you before man
i'm a huge fan of yours i'm a fan of
yours man hey let's let them work with
your friends work with people you like
exactly this though it feels like less
stress that way you know what i mean
that makes me happy everything's moving
and i i got to do a movie with adam
sandler once
and uh it was called sandy wexler sandy
wexler yes yes
and i was just watching how like there'd
be times where
kevin james is on set and he's not even
filming like he's just there in video
village tossing out jokes
like they just kick it and they hang out
and they have fun and his family's there
i'm like this is the life man like now
yeah i hear like sandler and i love
sandler i love adam so he he came up to
me once i did this movie that didn't do
very well i've done a few of those but a
movie called sorority boys and he goes
you're really funny in that man you're
[ __ ] hilarious in that movie i go
yeah thank you yeah but don't worry
about it you're funny who cares
you know he's really sweet i heard that
you know sometimes on set
somebody told me like he'll be like he
when he's giving direction to his friend
he's like come on you can be deliver it
like that turn your head and then say
the [ __ ] line yes does he do that
he does it
and it's the best because it's it's not
it's not like coming from some [ __ ]
director that you don't know right you
know what i mean like some [ __ ] who's
like really pretentious and feels like
their job is the best in the world and
they're all powerful and they want to
talk down to you as the actor he's
[ __ ] around with his friends you know
what i mean yeah i've seen him do it
i've seen him like his nephew i want to
say his nephew and even his agent was in
the movie i want to say or his manager i
think and he's yelling at them from
video villains and he's like just
sitting a [ __ ] line like this
you're supposed to be come on you act
like you never acted before come on do
it like this and then just like
shut
did he do it with you did he kind of
throw [ __ ] at you
uh he would not not in not in the that
kind of way but we would we would play
like there was a scene i remember when
we were at the dinner table
and uh and he we had to do this bit
where he's like choking he's like
talking and spitting out food and he's
like chicken at me and i'm like
kind of like disgusted with him but i'm
playing the scene so real
and so straight right and like and
he didn't know i was gonna play it that
way and so he got he goes [ __ ] come
on this dude is making me act [ __ ]
and he's like all right he regroups he
comes back
and
he comes back and then maybe like 20
minutes later we reshoot part of that
scene his coverage
and he and then he reminds you why he's
adam sandler like he comes back he's
improvising he's
heightening the scene he's low he's
playing high status low status he's
doing he's like an acting clinic after
he saw what i was going to do on my
coverage um so that's his most that's
the most
i've seen of him like make adjustments
and like get weird with me on sale he
was very like
so he's sort of he sort of does this
thing where he sees what you're gonna do
and then on his close-up he'll go for
instance if he's he's like uh you know
he says
lamorne how's this chicken and then
he'll do one where he's like the man has
his chicken you like this chicken and
then he'll do so
whatever it is you know or he's yelling
at you something that he's spitting on
your face he'll do
different vocal he'll be high he'll be
low he'll do everything so they have all
these choices
absolutely absolutely because you know i
imagine a lot of times especially in
comedy the tone is very
it's a delicate line you have to walk
when you're trying to figure out the
tone for the for an entire two hour film
and
in that scene in particular it could
have went so slap sticky based off of
what i could have done with the
performance but i i you know it's a
sandler movie so i wanted to just play
it real so his his comedy could get
heightened and be more polarizing and so
i played it straight and i played it it
was hard to do as well just because
again i'm sitting across my head of
silence so there are moments where i'm
breaking but i'm like stop starting
myself going on okay okay
and i'm playing it straight so you were
breaking you were breaking up he broke
you a few times
oh a million times like i mean a million
times did he like it do you think he
liked breaking you
i oh i know for a fact he did i know
what he did because there are times when
he's just doing it specifically to break
you
like he's seeing like moments of like
if i do a bit here it'll [ __ ] with him a
little bit right um that was fun man it
was fun it truly was like a clinic
working on that film
that's amazing
inside of you is brought to you by true
bill ryan this stuff is pretty genius
yeah it is i was just reading the uh i
was just putting the blurb on it i mean
i have already saved so much money on
this let me tell you about this is your
ex still using your netflix
that's what one woman found out after
she downloaded truebill which finds and
cancels subscriptions
with just a tap truebill is the new app
that helps you identify and stop paying
for subscriptions you don't need or want
or simply forgot about on average people
save up to 720 dollars a year with
truebill because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel truebill
makes it incredibly simple just link
your accounts and truebill will cancel
your unwanted subscriptions in one tap
and your truebill concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to folks
true bill has over 2 million users and
helped save more than 100 million
dollars for them
like becca l who says hands down the
best financial app i discovered in my
first week i opened up 187
in unused recurring subscriptions i'm
obsessed i never want to manage finances
without true bill again so don't fall
for subscription scams start canceling
today at truebuild.com slash inside go
right now truebill.com
inside it could save you thousands a
year
truebill.com slash inside inside of you
is brought to you by nitsa
you know it can be a little frustrating
especially if you're in a hurry or
you're running late to find yourself at
a railway crossing waiting for a train
and if the signals are going and the
train's not even there yet you may feel
a bit tempted to try and sneak across
the tracks
well don't ever to the naked eye trains
often appear to be farther away and
moving slower than they are and they
can't stop quickly folks
even if the engineer hits the emergency
brakes right away it could take a train
over a mile
to stop over a mile
by that time it's too late and the
result is a potentially deadly crash the
point is
you can't know how quickly the train
will arrive the train can't stop quickly
even if it sees you
it ends in disaster if the signals are
on the train is on its way and you just
need to remember one thing
stop
trains can't
brought to you by nitsa inside of you is
brought to you by me undies guys the
most comfortable underwear i've ever had
i i want to take my pants off right now
uh don't okay okay well i'm wearing them
now i swear on my life i'm wearing me
undies because they're the most
comfortable underwear i have ever ever
worn hands down i was thinking about i
was like should i take my pants off and
just have my underwear on for a wide
shot
but you know i don't maybe i don't need
to do that but you just have to take my
word for it that's extremely comfortable
ryan i know you don't want to see that i
trust you me undies believes that
comfort is about more than what's
touching your skin it's about feeling
comfortable in your skin and that's why
meundies not only use a sustainable
breathable soft as heck fabric but they
also give you endless styles to choose
from it's total comfort inside
and out i
like i said these things i
i you know they gave me a free pair i've
purchased six more pairs
with no discount
me andy's offers classic colors to
ridiculous prints it's all so you can
fully express yourself in your own
unique way and it comes uh in a range of
sizes me undies from extra small to 4xl
never leave your couch again with a me
undies membership a monthly subscription
that sends new pairs right to your door
yeah and each month you'll choose new
undies socks or a bralette and pick the
style and color or print that feels the
most you fun right plus enjoy discounted
prices free shipping and exclusive early
access to new launches love your butt
and get the membership meundies has a
great offer for our listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15 percent
off and free shipping me undies also has
their problem free philosophy if you're
not satisfied with any product for any
reason they'll refund or exchange it no
caveats and no questions
so to get your 15 off your first order
and free shipping just go to me undies m
e u m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s meundies.com
inside that's meundies.com
inside
um i was looking on your instagram and i
was like he wasn't in space jam was he
why did he get this big box of [ __ ]
what was that about i mean i saw this
big box of space jam [ __ ]
no not in space jam but like because of
the because of the pandemic people don't
have premieres anymore really you know
so what they do is they like send out
stuff
to people to post to bring awareness to
the film and i and i get them all the
time and i don't you know unless i have
like a
tie to the film somehow
i don't i won't post it really um or
unless i'm like obsessed with the movie
and i like you know
i'm not being paid you know what i mean
i'm just like a really big fan of space
jam and huge lebron fan and the director
malcolm lee is a buddy of mine i've
worked with him before so when i so i
thought you know yeah let's do it man
and i wanted to be a space channel
you [ __ ]
[Music]
you did was that a big favor he was
growing up with jordan
oh my god
michael jordan is everything he really
is do you think he's the best of all
time
well who's number one
lebron james you think lebron james is
number one over michael jordan
yes were you on crack of course it was a
different era
jordan just created everything all these
championships and the tongue out and the
just
jumping 100 feet and like i know i know
what do you think it is about lebron
that's better than jordan and how much
better if jordan's uh what number what
number is lebron
well
it's not that he's much better because
that's just impossible michael jordan
was damn near perfection right um
but
again i was watching these clips of
jordan
i mean he was he's again he's number two
all time before lebron he was number one
to me all right but i was watching i was
watching the competition that he was
going up against some of it was tough
and difficult but for the most part he
was scoring over like five ten guys the
guards were so small back then michael
jordan was like
i mean there was no way these guys we
had bill cartwright on his team
i know but he also had scottie pippen
rodman that's true you know it's steve
curve steve kirk would shoot the lights
out john paxton he had some some killers
around now you you
you like
lebron's shoes better that's for sure
actually
although i do have a sick lebron
collection it's reverse i actually like
jordan's shoes better you do but i don't
collect them like i like you know what i
mean like i collect the bronze but not
the jordans how much do you spend on a
pair of lebron shoes
probably like 250 something like that
250 and how many pair
i probably have
maybe
200 pair of lebrons
but but
but
a lot of them are free a lot of them are
given to me
you know what i mean get when i have
like a birthday someone would give me a
pair or nike kate back in the day would
send me
you know like a box of lebrons whenever
a new one would come out i would get
like some of them you know but for the
most part i was buying them right um
yeah
i i mean i don't have 200 pair shoes
people make fun of me because i probably
have 50 pairs of shoes but you have
hundreds of pairs of shoes do you do you
wear would you say you wear a lot of
them you try to everyday a new pair of
shoes
uh
you know what's so funny is that i know
i i may have like they're like i wear a
total of like four or five pair
and it's usually what's on my floor when
i'm walking out of my room so it's the
same pair usually for like a full week
and then if i know i'm going somewhere
where i have to look a certain way i'll
specifically pick a different pair of
shoes but for the most part i have these
shoes
they're called golden goose
they're just like these
low
top raggedy beat up looking shoes that i
put on i got as a gift and i just
i wear them damn near every day
and people give you [ __ ] because you're
not wearing all these other shoes you
have
right yeah i just can't you know
sometimes they don't
like lebrons are really bulky
right they look fantastic but they don't
match
like sometimes these skinny jeans that
i'm wearing you're very color
coordinated too aren't you like you like
to look sharp
yes and no yes and no i mean look i'm
wearing a red blood sports shirt with a
yellow hat i don't know if that is
coordinated it looks good to me it looks
better me i'm in a pair of sweats and a
freaking missile command shirt so you
look good man you know you know look at
you with your hairline on crisp and is
is it crisp is it intact
christmas time so i'm wearing a hat man
my hairline looks like what the [ __ ]
so yeah well look you have
obviously a ton of success and you've
done so many things and i always like to
go back
i mean you're from the south side of
chicago
yeah my engineer ryan over here was like
well that's that's the tough part of
chicago
i'm like is it was it it's not the north
it's the south it's always the south
but the south side did you was it a
tough childhood
yeah yeah it was man but you know when
you're in it as a kid you don't look at
it as tough because that's just what
you're used to
you know what i mean when i when i was a
kid i mean there was a lot of gang
violence a lot of fights a lot of
gunshots being shot at sometimes
stuff like that but you just looked at
it like
i remember the time being at the park we
played basketball at the park and people
started shooting
now we just ducked down and like ran off
and then like once we get a block away
you and your boys like laughing like
damn that was crazy
as opposed to going
we almost lost our lives like you know
it's just
it toughens you up to to the point where
not a lot of things get to you um
so you get you get used to it it's not
it's not the best way to get used to
something
because unfortunately a lot of kids
don't survive that a lot of families are
broken up by gang violence and drugs and
you know policing in some of these
neighborhoods but
it it
it definitely forms you in the way you
think when you when you get a little bit
older but
when we when i was
when i was
15 i want to say we moved to the burbs
like you go from the south side of
chicago which is like
like parts of it it's like the hood hood
and you move to like the western burbs
where you're where it is like suburbia
damn near you know what i mean it's like
people leave their doors unlocked and
you know [ __ ] like that you're like man
this is crazy
um
and it definitely changes the way you
think you start to see
the differences in the neighborhoods the
differences in your friends their
upbringings
you know what life was like for them
having a father around and you know and
you start to you start to see where
things could have been different for you
but you still appreciate where you come
from because there's a level of
awareness that i have that you know
certain kids didn't have right was your
father around
no no so my father uh
my father was actually deported back in
the day um back to belize
uh because my family's from belize um so
he got deported back because of drugs
you know um so you're selling a lot of
drugs this man melts a lot were you all
around that were you aware of that at a
young age you knew what was going on
oh yeah oh yeah yeah but again it was
normal
because everybody's daddies did it you
know what it was
and they did it in front in front of
their children
yeah you grew up i mean there were
crackheads
walking around sometimes you know we'd
come home sometimes like
[ __ ] would be missing from the house
you know
like
like we had a we had someone who lived
across the street
who used to just walk around butt naked
and walk out like and turn her water
homes on and put water in a bucket and
she was just like boobs out she didn't
care she was just he was on drugs and
this is how she was gonna live her life
and it was very normal to us and we were
like hey she was like hey y'all
and
she was like
sometimes she would leave the water on
and water bill would be high as [ __ ]
flooding our grass
yeah
was it a good looking woman was it
someone that you guys as kids would just
wait around for hoping that she would go
fill the bucket
no no no no
hopefully she's healthy and alive and
well now but back then when she was on
that stuff let me tell you something
nothing good kids there's nothing good
looking about drugs
there's nothing good looking about
but look so your dad he was deported and
then so your mom raised you
my mom yeah how hard was that
oh you know again for us normal but for
my mama was difficult you know what i
mean my mom's just working her butt off
um in the postal service right mostly
yeah post office raising four kids
grind and trying to even trying to and
then and then on her days off you know
that her days off she would do
she would spend every minute with us we
should take us to places we would do we
had normal child we had a fairly normal
childhood but it was just like
you grow up faster because you spend a
lot of that time learning stuff on the
fly on your own you know and for a lot
of that time my grandma my grandma was
around up until the time i was 12.
she passed away um so my grandmother
also helped raise us
um aunts uncles you know people it was
all hands-on they contributed people
contributed in the raising of you guys
south side man we used to spend a lot of
time on our aunt's house
um
you know i had
taught me how to cook a little bit
you know so it was it was a
very communal
type upbringing was she strict was mom
strict that you have to be i guess
she tried to be
but she realized how silly her kids were
and you know
like she couldn't do anything about it
you know like there
are also things we didn't really care
about doing like for me for example she
was stripped on like going out being out
late partying things like that but i
also never did that
you know i didn't have a desire to even
in high school i'm trying to remember i
haven't went to a party in high school
instead i went to like
we would go to my friend's house and
play video games
and
you know like get mountain dew and a
bunch of cheetos
mountain dew is my jam that is my jam
that's what we did at night
really so because if you would have gone
to those parties you probably would have
been in trouble
probably
probably so she would she would pretend
to be strict and be like i told you i
want you to button this house by this
time and i'm like
sure but she knew deep down like he's
he's around the corner at alex's house
or somebody playing right you know
mortal kombat or playing damn you know
nba 2k or something like that i wasn't
doing anything crazy right did you have
dreams like as a young kid we all have
dreams we always think but like when
you're a kid and you're in it like you
say
i mean are you thinking outside the box
you're growing up in the south side of
chicago then you move to suburbia but
still are you thinking
i want to be an actor i want to be funny
i want to be a comedian but you're
always thinking that
kind of but for me back then it was
back then it was more like i wanted to
be a basketball player you know what i
mean again michael jordan he was the
you everybody wants to be like mike and
i did too so i was like
i thought i was that good turns out i
was not
but those were more of my dreams being
in the sports world somehow but then
the older i got the more i felt i fell
in love with like goofing off and i
thought man this is i love going to
school because i get to just be silly
and weird and my teachers encouraged it
they encouraged you to be silly and
goofy
oh yeah oh absolutely see they didn't do
that with me they they go rosenbaum out
in the hallway
rosenbaum get in the corner i just
didn't get me and they just would kick
my ass out and so i got the best revenge
and success but they were never they
were never like
excited about my behavior
you know what i mean but but they were
encouraging you to be a goof in class
like you were they were you disruptive
in class
oh absolutely
i love your teachers who are these
teachers they have to tell you something
glenbard south high school
they they did a great job with their
hiring of staff
because they were obviously very
disciplined in their in their curriculum
but at the same time they knew it was
less about it was less about what can we
throw on these kids to do it but it was
it was more about okay what what do
these kids have and how can we use their
strengths to get them to learn better
and to get those kids to do what they're
supposed to do better and i had you know
math teachers english teachers even my
music teachers and things like that they
were all they knew that these kids were
wild and rambunctious and weird and so
they would encourage the behavior i had
one teacher who had kicked me out he
would give me time to like tell jokes in
class
and then he would go but you go you get
but i'll give you the time to tell these
jokes but afterwards you got to go to
the principal's office
or you could just shut up
and let me
teach
and i would do both certain days i just
wouldn't be feeling it you know
i'll let you do your thing today
wow but did you think you want to study
yeah did you learn do you feel like
because they allowed this freedom that
you had more of a respect for them that
you learned more and that you were you
got a little bit of an education because
of that
yeah because you felt you felt for me a
lot of times if i didn't understand
something
i would be too shy in front of everybody
to be like i don't get it i didn't want
to be the dumb that was me
yeah would just pretend like i knew what
they were talking about and then fail
the test and i'd be like
so when you get that um
when you develop that shorthand with
teachers it's okay to be like
and and you develop that that
that cynical attitude you can just flat
out say look i don't understand what
you're talking about and then other kids
would go yeah yeah me either actually
and then
it was a very encouraging space to be
like okay we're not you don't have to be
a rocket science it's just algebra like
let's figure it out you know wow
i tried to i was advanced in certain
certain subjects and then they put me in
physics
um ap physics
and
i remember day one ap physics i sat down
and i was sitting in this like lab
everyone's talking the teachers talking
we're discussing something and i stopped
and i went time out
i don't think i'm supposed to be in here
they were like what do you mean to go
this is the class you signed up for i go
yo well they recommended it
they're like
i said i haven't taken physics the basic
version this is ap physics
what the [ __ ]
they're like oh okay maybe we should
demo you a little bit i was okay with
that i was like i don't need to be here
i don't need to stress myself out here
yeah uh
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna be a clown when
i grow up anyway so
inside of you is brought to you by geico
uh guys i don't know about you but i
like easy stuff i like to go to the not
go to the grocery store i like
things delivered to me
um
boy geico makes it easy to pay your
homeowners renters insurance or your
auto policy you just do it in one fell
swoop and it's done it's geico easy you
got to try this they're bundling
policies
uh
you know i
pay a mortgage you rent we've talked
about that and uh we just got so much
going on in our lives and geico is here
to make life a little easier so why
don't you use geico it's simple you
don't have to pay three different people
you just pay geico with their bundling
policy um we have so much to do around
the house and in life in general just go
to geico.com it's that easy you get a
quote see how much you could save it's
geico easy visit geico.com today
that's
geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at betterhelp betterhelp
online therapy i don't know how much to
tell you every guest it seems like that
is on the podcast they're talking about
therapy they're talking about how it
works for them so i urge you to use
better help online therapy ryan does
better help
and it's been helping him substantially
i've noticed a big difference in your
disposition
and uh you know i appreciate you being
so forthcoming and like talking about
like how it helps you yeah it's just
been sort of here on the podcast we've
been talking about week after week and
this has been a very
stressful year for a lot of different
reasons and i think it helps yeah and
you know if you listen to the podcast
you're realizing that not just
you know regular folks
get anxiety and depression and deal with
a lot of stuff but big celebrities and
you know we all we're all human we all
come from the same place and we're all
going to the same place so we all deal
with our
[ __ ] this is true you know like if
you're feeling depressed or struggling
with uncertainty or having difficulty
sleeping better help offers experienced
therapists who can listen
and help betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
uh you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses that you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as with traditional therapy
we all know how that can be
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
you need and i've been through many
counselors and you just got to find the
one that's right for you and better help
will certainly help you with that
it's more affordable by a long shot if
you ask me then traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
so many people have been been using
betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
it's a no-brainer guys if things are
bottling up and you have any anger
issues or whatever just see a therapist
talk to better help online counseling
this podcast inside of you is sponsored
by better help online therapy our
listeners get 10 off their first month
of online therapy at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelp.com
inside
get matched with a better help therapist
and get started
i mean so when when it wasn't you
decided did you get involved in high
school theater and did they have theater
and is that what happened you got
involved in that
i did i did i i um
i was used to my time being spent
playing basketball after school and
things like that and you know summer
league and all that stuff like that but
then after i after i realized
how i was not that good and i got cut
and
i was like i need i need to figure out
how i'm some how else am i going to
spend my time
and uh
i took a radio and tv class
um which is like how to be a radio host
how to
you know how to work the sound boards
how to you know do this all the
technical stuff i took a class doing
that in high school and i realized i
liked the speaking part better um and
then another i started looking through
the curriculum that the school offered
and another one was theater
i was like oh i did a church play once i
wonder i wonder how this will will pan
out for me and then i'd never stop doing
it
did you do you remember the first play
you did and the reaction you got the
response
well the
for i could tell you the first big play
i did one play where i played like i had
like one or two lines i forget what it
was called but it was dog [ __ ] uh but
then the second player i did was was was
called god spell oh yeah and god's spell
is
amazing musical and i got to play in
that
and
the reaction i got was amazing i'm
talking we had a pretty dope theater in
high school it's a big big theater so i
was also in concert choir in men's choir
so you could sing you're a singer
well
uh
let's just say that when i sing panties
melt all over the world
of course they do i get the message i
get the tweets you know what i mean so i
know they're melting um
so but
i know i'm a goofy singer i can i can
carry a tune right but i'm not like i'm
not putting out a singing album a rap
album yeah but not a single you like to
play you want to have you you have an
element of play in everything you do
yes yes and so you sang in god's spell
i sang in god spell
i i i want to say my first in high
school i played a character named herb
he was this really silly goofy weird guy
would pop up in and out and you're
in gospel everyone's on stage at the
same time for the most part um
throughout the whole thing and it's
takes place in like a park or in a city
it's so it's like all these moving parts
and moving pieces and my character was
really funny and the crowd loved it and
i and funny funny thing is that in
college i got to play
in godspell again
the musical
and so and then i played a different
character i played john the baptist who
had to do more solo singing which was a
little scary
but that dude you did you did it i
survived i survived wow was your mom
really proud of you do you remember when
you when you did the god spell in high
school that you remember her saying
you've got something there kid you you
got something
oh yeah she's been doing that since uh
since i was a lot younger actually she
my mom wanted to uh to be an actor back
in the day but obviously having kids and
things like that kind of slows that
slows that down she you know she writes
poems and you know she's a very art
artsy and creative person
um and especially you know being in the
church she she was very
proud that i was in godspell you know
what i mean it's about jesus and and
that was something that was uh was
really cool for her to see and uh
yeah and she still is my mom used to
take me to all my auditions
you know she would take sometimes she
would take time off work she would call
in late for work because you know she
had to drive me to the audition or take
me to these castings and do all this you
know she was a hands-on mom with with my
career and you think she's a very like i
saw some interview where you go my mom
is one of the funniest people i know
oh yeah she's hilarious you really think
your mom is because i don't think my mom
is one of the funniest people i know
i don't that's so far is so far-fetched
that i like
she's out there but like you genuinely
get a kick out of your mother
that's a rarity yes my mom called me
just down but maybe maybe 10 minutes
before i got on with you
my mom called me just to shoot the [ __ ]
but she goes
the first thing that she started doing
was hello son
how are you
and i was like i'm fine mom and she goes
your day going well so far
yes and she goes so did i get the part i
said
no you did not
no i knew it was you i knew
you like the part she does that she'll
prank call me sometimes and do that's
her favorite voice to do for years she's
been doing that voice when she calls
she's not giving up on that voice that's
her go-to
that's her go-to so if anyone ever needs
skeletor
cartoon like any any raspy kind of
cigarette smoking voice my mom can do it
she doesn't smoke cigarettes but she
sounds like she sounds like she does so
you started doing like a lot i noticed
how many commercials and i i told ryan
here i said ryan
look how many commercials this guy's
done i mean he's done commercials i
never got asked to do one commercial i
thought
i started to get a complex i was like
why doesn't anybody want me in a
commercial i would do voice over stuff
eventually but never on camera
start man that was live i don't know man
but there was a long stretch before that
where i auditioned for commercials and i
never got them i think it's because i
had these fangs that they fixed
eventually
i had these big dracula fangs and no one
wanted to see that [ __ ] on tv
oh man well maybe not colgate but you
know everything else
colgate
yeah no i man dude i started doing so
many commercials at one point i didn't
realize i was doing that many i i was
broke i was living in my car at one
point like i was
you know borrowing money
you know to pay rent to pay bills and
you know literally borrowing food from
friends like hey can i borrow chicken
breast you know i was doing stuff like
that just to make it
in la
and then one day my car got rebowed
didn't have means to get back and forth
to these auditions and i lived in north
hollywood
and i live right on lake right off
lancashire in north hollywood what year
was this
this was in
08 09 this is not that long ago
no
not that long ago you were living in a
car yes
wow
0809 around that time
and then i remember
i remember
a buddy of mine moving to l.a we got an
apartment together
and the car got rebowed because we both
weren't doing very well but
combining our resources together we
could afford this apartment
and we we got in
but we were also struggling to pay bills
you know and car got repo and i remember
having to borrow either my neighbor's
car to go to auditions or take the bus
so i took the bus in l.a it's not the
easiest you're going from north
hollywood to santa monica
it would take this three hour trip just
to get in there and go these oreos taste
great there we go thanks so much you go
all right back on this goddamn bus
three hours to say that
man and then one day i was late
and that was late for an audition for
miller lite
and i get there and they're like did you
read the sides i said yeah
i'm sweating
and i didn't i know they had the big
tell like the big board with the
commercial written out right behind the
camera so i was like i'll just i guess
i'll just [ __ ] wing it and i go in
there and that's what i did i i was
winging it and improvising and that's
when i realized like that might be my
strength because i booked it right on
the spot
and they they were other people waiting
they had sent some of the other guys
home
and then they had me stay
and read with the other girls that were
there
in the casting and so i was confused
when they had sent everybody home and
they asked me to stay i was like oh okay
i said well that's never happened before
they were like can you read with this
person and that person i was like yeah
absolutely and while doing that i
started coming to the realization that i
think i booked this
i think that's and that commercial was
kind of what set the tone for the rest
of the rest for the rest of them because
i started getting offers for commercials
and
uh
not a known person at this point in my
career something you're late to you're
late to this thing you're sweating and
you just start to improvise kind of for
the first time
of improvising in commercials
and this is what takes your career off
something that you never would expect
you would have been on time you would
have been sweating you would have given
them what they wanted you thought what
they wanted
absolutely it's like going rock bottom
man you start to you start to rely on
your instincts
you know and our instincts is what
makes us who we are you know if we are
all if you and i go in for the same
audition and you and i studied at the
same acting school and you and i have
the exact same mannerisms you know
they're going to just go do we want to
go with a black guy or white guy same
there's no difference between these two
performers
but if you have i don't know a lisp or
if you have a thing that you do they're
going to go but you know michael has
that thing that he does that's different
that's something we haven't seen let's
let's go let's go with him and for me it
was improv it was a lot of cats know how
to do it but when you're acting you we
we fail to
we we forget that that's a part of who
we are and we stick to the script so
much and when they're casting for
something they see 50 of those guys
all doing the same thing yeah
that's so true you've got to
differentiate yourself you've got to
adventure yourself
but you know but you got to go back to
you doing second city and that had to
attribute to that that had to help that
situation correct
oh absolutely second city was like the
biggest part of my career and
i mean
it's it's literally a facility to go
play in and you start to turn that into
a skill set and you're working with
people who want to do the same thing you
do and you guys are all creating
together you're on stage you're telling
jokes you're writing jokes you're
creating characters
um and so when you get older you don't
realize that that's now ingrained in you
it's not like let me sit down and open
my second city book and remember what's
been taught to me and no you just
it becomes your personality where you
like being silly
and uh
and it definitely helps out definitely
helps out who's your favorite improviser
of all time who's your favorite second
city member
second city or groundlings whoever it is
somebody that you just go man that's the
person that makes me laugh the most
mine's always been farley and i know
that you won the chris farley award
i did yes i did win the chris farley
scholarship for for college and
i i would there's a few because i've
worked with some great second city
people as well and there's some that you
just admire from afar you know steve
carell and
um you know tj miller um
but for me it was it's probably there's
two guys
uh this guy named edgar blackman that i
worked with it was always him and i on
stage together
he like himself along with
a guy named tim baltz
and sam richardson
so
sam richardson
is
like
like another level goofy
i got to work i i worked with him once
in second city i came back as an alumni
and did a show with him i did like a set
with him
they had a show called south side of
heaven
it was i think tim robinson um tim baltz
edgar blackman sam richardson i forget
who else is in the cast but it was one
of the greatest shows i've ever seen
like of all time like for over any
production and i've seen hamilton okay
right the south side of heaven is better
than hamilton wow
and sam richardson was a big big part of
that and i got to work with him on new
girl i mean he's a buddy of mine now but
you when you so he's probably
he probably tops that list for me for
people i've
yeah how long did you struggle when you
started to get these commercials you cut
it just catapulted right it was like a
domino effect so so you started getting
these but did you start to think
i want to act i'm doing commercials but
now i want to go to the next step i mean
next stage and did you have that agent
who can get you to those auditions or
were you just dealing mostly with
commercial agents
yeah i didn't have a theatrical agent i
just had commercial agents and
you know it it was going good until it
wasn't meaning i was looking at
i was going into the agency off like the
agency to pick up like checks because i
was getting a lot of them because i was
doing a lot of commercials and i was
like man this is this is crazy
how i'm on i remember going into my
agent's office one time and they had
theatrical agents there
at it was called their first talent
group
and i pretty much was like the head of
their commercial division
you know but i couldn't get a meeting
with the theatrical agent to save my
life jesus
i go in there one time this guy goes he
goes hey man
dude you're all over my [ __ ] tv man
you were just playing on our tv here man
and i was like
okay
well [ __ ] sign me then wrong with you
what's wrong i'm clearly doing something
right he's like yeah man we're gonna
take a look man you know we're gonna
we're gonna take a look man you know how
it is man i don't
know how it is
tell me how it is
yeah and so didn't couldn't get a
meeting with those guys and then i
noticed that my check started slowing up
like i was like man
i'm still working my courses are airing
like a lot
like you can turn on tv i'm like three
spots in one commercial break and
i was like what's going on they're like
oh something's wrong with the mailing
system and it's this and it's that and
then mysteriously they found a bunch of
checks of mine just kind of sitting in a
drawer somewhere they're like oh there
you go how much money were in those all
those checks it was like fifty thousand
dollars worth of sex i'm talking it was
like a box like like a stack i was like
what
i was like
you just found them like what would have
happened if i would if i would have said
anything then i then i go then they go
under they go out of business
and i re and i find that they have
they have taken me for over a hundred
grand
wow and they were robbing a lot of the
actors
and that's when i started getting checks
signed over to myself but not to the
agent
yeah it was it was uh i still haven't
resolved that it was bad holy [ __ ]
so i left that agency well i would hope
you'd leave that agency what now so then
you you got an agent because then you
started getting auditions for things
yes i started getting i i so a buddy of
mine
was signed to an agency global artist
agency until this day they've been they
were like i'm not with them anymore but
at the time
they they definitely believed in me at
least one agent there wanted to start a
commercial division there so she said
okay look i'll take you on
if you bring if you come if you sign
with us
commercially and i said okay great and
out the gate i started booking
commercials for them
they're like it worked out i was like
well let's let's talk about these uh
theatrical auditions though
and then within two months of being with
this agency i was on new girl
and that's such a story that you've
probably told a million times but the
first thing i thought of was like i
wonder if you ever thanked damon wayans
jr for not coming back to the show i
wonder if he actually said thank you
cause man my [ __ ] took off
all the time all of you know it
yeah damon's the homie like we yeah we
always trying to develop together and uh
he's uh
he's the the best like he's he's a cool
dude and he was so he was on the show he
was the pilot but he had a conflict with
another show that he was doing with
happy endings and so he couldn't do it
so instead of writing the character off
instead of like replacing the character
they just wrote him off and then just
hired you for the second episode
right
in a nutshell that's what happened it's
a lot longer than that but pretty much
that's how it went down um
prior to it i want to say
i don't know if he auditioned or didn't
but prior to it i got an offer to play
that role of coach but i had a prior
engagement i had a prior obligation to
cbs and i'm talking within hours we were
trying to get them to make an offer for
me
for new girl after i had auditioned a
couple times
and it was like why are we making an
offer he's got a test like everybody
else and and my agents were saying well
because cbs is making him an offer from
another show
and they were like impossible like
nobody again he's done a few commercials
but like you know and so cbs was i was
let me at the test for new girl and
before you signed that contract
i got a call from my agent saying don't
sign the contract we got an offer cbs
i was like oh
it was this pilot called the assistance
it was uh with tj miller and heather
locklear david henry sarah wright
jason jones it was a great great show
the pilot was really funny the cast was
amazing
it just didn't go
and in that
time damon had signed up to do new girl
not knowing if he could actually
officially do it because he did he said
he had happy endings right so everything
just started working out him leaving
me having me come back in for a new
character that i auditioned 15 times for
you auditioned 15 times for for your
character yes well 11 for my character
11 for my character i want to say and
then the other times for coach
11 times what do they need to see
that they won't see if they rewound the
tape on the first one
i don't know
were you doing anything different were
you doing anything different
they would change the material up a
little bit here and there but i was like
just imagine that i said it
like how i said the other joke
at one point i started losing hope i was
like i don't think i want to
i remember the last part the last leg of
this audition i tested maybe three or
four times i want to say
and i remember the last
audition i had i thought i booked it
like jake johnson
emailed me it was like
he's like dude i think you got it
i was like oh my god that's awesome then
it gives me a call right back
oh so there's this kid
there's justin heyers and justin heyer's
he's on macgyver right now
is a [ __ ] stud
so when they told me justin was reading
i was like
damn it
i saw this for nothing i was like here
comes justin's
punk ass gonna take my job
and luckily i i booked it um um
but yeah i mean justin's doing
how did that feel how'd that feel when
you finally they said you're in
i i cried immediately like i didn't know
how to react because my and funny enough
my mom was in town too visiting so
you're both crying
yeah my mom was in town i got in the car
and called her
it was just like
i did it i did she's like okay what i
was like
i did it she was just like she's on the
phone crying i'm on the phone crying
um
i think back to the i think back to that
time
often and it always brings a smile on my
face just because i know how hard i i
worked leading up to that um i've since
gotten lazy but prior to that oh my god
what a worker i was that's what happens
that's what happens we get older and we
do less
i don't think that's true with you you
work just as hard
i do but it's i'm trying to funnel my
energy into other aspects of
entertainment you know what i mean to
things that i have more of my control
over and that are more fun for me like
i'm going to get to the podcast space
i've already taken a dive into it a
little bit and producing and
writing more and
i
you know i want to do what you do man
what what do i do
she can talk to cool ass people dude
shoot the [ __ ] you know what everybody
there's so many people doing it now
that's become a little bit like holy
[ __ ] it's a little like overwhelming
it's like why are people gonna listen to
the show well you hope so that you have
good guests on you probably know a lot
more famous people than i do
no absolutely not you know common you
just did an album with common you damn
right don't you forget it i'm not
forgetting it
i haven't forgotten it since you told me
so eight seasons of this which is like
your first tv show and it goes
seven seasons most people's i did i did
a show we did a pilot then i did another
show we did eight episodes then i did
another show we did ten episodes you do
your first show you book
well i guess the one before you did the
pilot right yeah but but really
relatively you you jump right into seven
seasons of a hit show
yeah
yeah i tell you you get you get jaded
because you think this is how life is i
know like oh my god i struggled and then
i'm not gonna struggle anymore right
wrong right you know you after the show
goes off you're like okay what next and
then there's this this is like lull this
period of
you know of years where you're like uh
you might do a couple gigs here and
there but you don't know
if anything is going to satisfy you the
way
or take your career to another level or
you can get comfortable you know what i
mean and not stress about getting a gig
and
and even when you do get a gig you think
people are going to be as cool as the
people
where on new girl
and uh
sometimes it works out sometimes it's
not it doesn't was the cast that great
did you always have so much fun it was
just very collaborative and always a
good time oh my god yeah i mean we're
all friends to this day you know we're
always trying to find projects for us to
do together we're always like
you know we jump at those opportunities
to do these reunion panels and things
like that and we're just because you we
genuinely
enjoyed it we we had fun we we goofed
off
our characters were very different from
each other so we could live in those
spaces and play and
and
you know it was it was it was amazing i
might have to beg you to get me zoe on
the podcast sometime
that's uh easy was she cool like that
yeah
she seems so cool
yeah especially now in her life like in
our lives everything she's comfortable
she's like hey i just want to have fun i
want to host the show over here i might
do a movie i might not let me do a
podcast she's like yeah let's do it
who's who's having fun i want to do that
that's great that's kind of how she is
and tell me about woke
oh man woke is like
hulk is amazing woke is uh
i've always wanted to play a character
that existed or lived like i thought
like i want to play martin luther king
like in a movie
like i'm trying to figure out how to
play martin luther king in a comedy i'm
not 100 sure how that's gonna work you
could do it you could figure it out i
would figure it out
um and and then i got the opportunity i
got i got a
like post new girl again you get some
scripts here and there for certain shows
and a lot of them were kind of just like
way too slap sticky and weird and i was
like i just got through doing that with
new girl and i was like i want to do
something that's uh that's kind of
relevant culturally
at least something that people will talk
about
and when i read the script i was like
holy [ __ ] this is it this is the script
this is the how do i how do i how do i
get in how do i get involved
and um
you know
met with the director met with the guy
who the show was based on so for those
who haven't seen it woke is about
a cartoonist a guy named keith knight
who's alive and well
but you know he was a cartoonist in san
francisco in the 90s and
he was in a punk band he was a black
dude who was in a punk band who likes
hockey you know what i mean so and his
yeah his comics reflected that so people
when they would meet him at comic con
and things like that they would go
i didn't know you were black yeah and
he's like should i have written it down
somewhere
yeah and so
his the show is about you know his walk
politically where it's down in the
middle of the road he doesn't think
racism exists he doesn't let the the his
neighbor's problems bother him he just
wants to keep his head down and make
boring old comic strips for his fans and
that's it right until one day
the show is about the the situation we
use in the show is that one day he gets
um mistake his identity gets mistaken
for a criminal while he's putting up
flyers for a show and he gets beat up a
little bit by the police
and when he's
when he comes from that moment he starts
to go crazy a little bit when he starts
seeing things
and
like really saying things and these
comic strips these cartoon characters
these inanimate objects start talking to
him and they start forming the way
his art looks um
i have a racist marker that's played by
jb smooth
and you directed him in an episode that
you wrote in uh new girl right yeah damn
yep so
he he came on and killed it we have said
the entertainer plays a talking trash
can
i saw that yeah it's amazing we got man
we got little rel we got uh sam uh sam
sam richardson and tony hale they play
this toast and butter that talks to me
um
and i think that i like come on please
you can do it and they argue and they
fight each other and it shot so well too
it looks really good when you talk about
it it could easily come i don't know
that sounds good it's so well shot guys
you need to take a look at this and i
know that you also
you struggled because you kept shutting
down because of covet right the second
season yeah is that the season
we got shut down maybe three times i
want to say
um but you know we and
i'll say this the shutdowns weren't
because things were getting out of hand
the shutdowns were more so just to be
safe
you know what i mean i think sony did a
great job of kind of
making sure every and we had coveted
people on set that were overly cautious
which i think which i think is is is
good in that setting you know what i
mean because if one person gets sick the
last thing you need is for 100 people to
get yeah you know what i mean and so you
know an effort to stop the spread i
guess you kind of have to all right the
dude over there was driving the truck
guy covered everybody go home like let's
who
who you've been around let's test
everybody again let's make sure
everybody's good to go let's get back to
work um and so they were
you know they they i think they did what
they needed to do and they they handled
it uh
correctly where can we see woke
hulu
who guys
make sure y'all watch it if you don't
watch it guys
one
f you you know what i mean um
and i won't you know and i'll stop
watching you guys
i don't know what that means by the way
didn't you just do a horror movie
i did i'm a huge horror fan and
everybody who knows me knows i'm a
die-hard what kind of horror movie was
it was it paranormal was it
psychological was it like blood and guts
what was it
it was a little of all those things it
was psychological
paranormal it's like imagine shutter
island
on
crack
yeah really
yeah phoebe tonkin um
oh gosh she crushes it in this in this
movie and we have you know um the china
brothers these two guys are
night shift night shift
shift yep night shift wait is this out
no not yet no yeah we just wrapped um
that's what you just wrapped that's why
you couldn't be on the podcast earlier
because you were wrapping that
yes
yes i'm excited about this one i'm
excited about this one dude i can't wait
people to see it i play a weirdo i i
what i just oh my god i don't yeah
you probably won't recognize me in this
movie physically you will but
i have
oh it's good man i tell you i can creep
have you done don't say anymore don't
ruin it but did you have you done a
horror movie before this
oh man
i was hoping you didn't break well then
don't talk about it if you didn't like
it [ __ ] hope you didn't bring this
[ __ ] up man i've already pissed you off
at least i pissed you off towards the
end it's [ __ ] man asking me these
questions about the freaking okay fine
i'll tell you since you're pulling my
dick about it
i did a movie called april fools it was
my first movie okay it was trash
you didn't like it
no i didn't like it i get killed in the
first five minutes of the movie uh oh of
course you didn't like it
i'll talk now wait a minute i thought
those days were over where they killed a
black guy in the first five minutes what
the [ __ ] that about not when it's all
black cast oh then that's okay
yeah somebody got it no they should have
killed the white guy in the first five
minutes yeah they should have that yeah
dominican we had a dominican guy named
ramses jimenez
looks white sometimes but he's dominican
as hell man and so they were like no i
can't kill him
so they killed me
killed me man yeah he's another actor
too so they're just getting rid of the
the terrible actor first i guess hey uh
lamorin this is uh called [ __ ] talking
with lamorin morris this is uh rapid
fire or you could answer however you
want uh these are my patrons they
they're the patrons they subscribe to
the podcast they do extra for the
podcast here we go little lisa what's
your biggest fear
uh dying in a plane crash
damn you're my dog i so scared of flying
man so scared of flying like if there's
a bump i freak out and look around like
jeffy that [ __ ] too
you know why don't we have parachutes on
planes that's the commercial like if i'm
sitting first class goddammit i should
have a parachute again your meals are
shitty give me a parachute what's the
worst thing though surviving a plane
crash or dying in a plane crash do you
really want to survive
i do i would love to survive
i
would love to survive because you know
i'm going to sue for a billion dollars
all right that makes sense you went
there you went there yeah that makes
more sense dave p are you a cat person
as much as winston was
absolutely not hell no you don't own an
animal
i do not own an animal not at all but
you know my house has turned into a bit
of a dog park because all my friends
bring their damn dogs to my house i got
doggy bowls everywhere dog beds well you
allow it
dogs are cool they [ __ ] everywhere and
sometimes like jen you know you and your
damn dog danielle i'm just naming my
friends
morgan y'all dog mickey y'all dogs be
[ __ ] and like y'all gotta clean it
up sometimes i'm not doing it
i know the answer to this question by
the way dana asks what role have you
played that you wish you hadn't
april fools april fools okay i'm telling
you
what what is uh leanne p what's
something
what is something people be surprised to
learn about you besides all your shoe
collection of lebron james and jordan's
surprise to learn about me
oh i don't know i i i'm very i'm very
out there with things that actually
people a lot of people don't know i have
a daughter
people don't know that about me really
yeah cause i don't like i'm not i posted
once about her i took it down i'm not
i'm not one of those like i can't i
don't know there's something about
posting my kid that i'm like feels weird
to me like i want to do it i like want
to brag about her she's amazing like
it's just yeah you just feel
uncomfortable posting about her and
you're like want to keep that private
sort of yeah now you could you say baby
mama you have a baby mama do you get
along
with the child's mother see for a white
guy i can't say baby mama for some
reason just doesn't come out naturally
sound right i'm like um so the baby mama
of the uh it just doesn't sound right so
the the child's mother uh so you guys
get along are you you know is it is it
difficult to get along i mean you know
you have your ups and downs but it's
normal stuff like we get along yeah
it's not i mean we're just not in a
relationship you know it's hard to
travel back and forth and you know do
the scheduling and all that stuff like
that i get it maybe
but we get along i like it i like it and
h what's your favorite hobby that you do
when you get stressed out or sick i do
adult coloring books suzanne i do other
adult things ah
i'm kidding uh
am i though uh no i uh
no i play i play basketball i have a
basketball hoop in my backyard and if i
get like super stressed out i just go
shoot around for a little bit i'll play
with you sometime
you sure are good i'm not i'm not good
but like i pick stuff up i play a lot of
sports
so if you just showed me some
fundamentals i grew up in indiana i
watched a lot of basketball i never
played because i was always short as a
child but if you showed me a few things
i at least it'd be fun we'd have a good
that's what we're gonna do all right i
want everybody out there to go and look
up lethal shooter on instagram
lethal shooter this guy doesn't miss the
shooting coach he's come to my house
before
it'd be great to get you and lethal
shooter together
it would be a it would be an amazing
episode of your podcast you guys can
talk while he teaches you how to shoot
and this guy is i'm telling you he's
when i say he creates all these weird
inventions like hoops with spikes and he
shows you how he can just get the ball
right in there without a ball exploding
or he'll he'll be on one boat and have
another boat with a hoop going by and he
won't miss
and he's
that good he coaches nba players
everybody celebrities so we get a free
coaching lesson he'll show me how to
shoot a basketball that's all i need
somebody to really show me how to shoot
a basketball yes lethal shooter lethal
shooter michelle kay last question what
do you want your legacy to be
lamorne
your legacy
the ultimate teammate i and that's just
in life but that's also in my career man
i just love collabing with people and
again that's why that's why i love adam
sandler so much because it's family and
his friends and he if i can help
somebody achieve their goals and their
dreams
i would love to you know what i mean you
use the the one thing you know how to do
which is perform and use that to help
everybody else achieve their things you
know what i mean so you really want to
lift everybody else up too
you're a team player oh my god if we're
all winning if everyone's winning and
you know
and and if everyone's helping people and
you know being philanthropic and you
know just trying to
everyone every people on planet earth
man we just want to enjoy life
i think everybody but some people are
struggling you know um
if we can help people let's do it man
let's let's let's do it and i think
especially with me being an actor a lot
of my friends are actors and you know if
i ever have opportunity to help friends
out in that space i do it and and i you
know like work my boat off to to get to
a place where i have the ultimate say to
hire people
that are friends and family or control
the power the power to do that if you
have the ability the power to do that
that's that's sweet and i believe you
that's the thing i believe what you're
saying there's a lot of people who are
just in it for themselves they just want
to be billionaire trillionaires an
empire
and they don't care about the little
people but you want to kind of bring the
bring your friends along with for the
ride
oh absolutely absolutely that is a
that's i get more satisfaction out of
like going to my friend's premieres than
my own
yeah i'll leave you with this um my
friend dax i did a movie
and
he texted me during the movie of my
premiere
and said this movie's so bad i can't
believe i'm not in it
and i thought because it was a bad movie
and i laughed my dick off
and another funny story as i did this
movie
uh
it was just funny he was kidding around
because we love jamie kennedy but jamie
kennedy we did this movie and i was
kidding i go i'm never doing another
jamie kennedy movie just joking around
and miguel nunez who's hilarious goes
[ __ ] he's like jamie kennedy
never doing another jamie kennedy movie
so dude before we go can i ask
pool hall junkies
did you you saw that
did i see it i had the poster in my room
wow and the poster in my room me and my
friends we started going to pool that's
what that's why i started playing pool
was because i loved that movie so much
um
like even [ __ ] christopher walken i
was like it was great what the [ __ ]
that monologue he gives you guys were
you guys were clicking on all cylinders
man you know that was funny because that
movie i got the call the night before
and the director said hey can you get on
a plane in the morning and you're gonna
play my brother
and i just got on a plane and i learned
my lines in the plane and i and i did it
and i was like every day on set when
paul and terry's working or uh
rod steiger or christopher walken i
would just watch
walk and to see that inflection he has
you said it joe
bet it all
you would do that thing and
i would talk to him and he
it was just like it was it was a fun
it's one of those independent movies
where you're like man i wish this would
have blown up but people still come to
me and they say hey i really enjoyed the
movie and it was good to be
a part of something that was you know
people liked
so thank you man
liked i loved it there's i even remember
small bits of the movie like continuity
things that were funny like um uh what
was uh you just said his name um the
older guy robert tiger
yeah yes he he had the head on on one
scene he's talking he's at the pool hall
and then they cut and they come back to
him and his hat's like this
i think i remember that
i lost him independent i remember one
day walken was just pissed off because
he's supposed to be filming and he's
been waiting in his trailer for hours
and he walks out and the director's name
is mars and he looks at mars he says
moz
today's my last day and he walked out
and they're like we're like oh [ __ ]
he's like i better go talk to mr walken
he's like i'm done i've been waving my
trailer for hours
i'm done moz
you know i'm like dude you're getting
paid a million dollars for being here
for like a week
but uh he was he was cool he was cool
well i appreciate that man i love your
work and i hope you think of me when
you're doing something because you're
always uh thinking of new things and
doing great things and uh this has been
a real treat for me i'm gonna keep in
touch with you whether you like it or
not no please do man you got my email
put my number in there dude please man
please please i love you guys i love
this and i didn't know i don't know you
so i was sort of like he seems great i
don't you know my friend joe latruglio
from uh
brooklyn nine-nine i just said hey i'm
about to talk to a little more more oh
dude he's awesome you're going to love
him yeah and it seems like we know a lot
of the same people but i'm i'm so glad
you were such a good sport and you were
so funny and so good to talk to you and
uh i just appreciate it and let's keep
in touch man thank you man thanks for
having me i really do appreciate it of
course it was my pleasure man all my
love i'm going to email you right after
this so you better email me okay
all right cool all right
take it easy bro see ya
yeah he just was uh
easy to talk to had great stories i love
the sandler story i love uh just kind of
getting in his head and how he feels
about everything and he's just he's a
go-getter you know what i mean he's been
around
and uh
he's he's just a magnetic yeah
personality
i like him i want to hang out with this
guy yeah that's cool for guests that you
don't know beforehand yes because you
get anxious about how it's going to go
and this went very well yeah i always
get anxious yeah i always get anxious
before guests and you know my therapist
is like why don't you just enjoy it and
get excited about it and i do but then i
always think i'm going to run out of
things to say and people are like you
don't ever run out of things to say
that's not entirely true well no you you
really don't
yeah that's really fine well all right
thanks ryan i need ryan here i need ryan
by my side he's uh
he's good he's you're the goods i'm just
i'm like a [ __ ] rainbow you're a
[ __ ] rainbow delight is what you are
my friend and i love having you around
uh hey if you're uh still listening and
you enjoy the podcast please subscribe
you can watch the shows on youtube you
can listen um the handle you can listen
anywhere the podcasts exist
we've been getting a lot of press lately
stephen amell episode and lots of others
so um hopefully you'll spread the word
and continue it um also i'm on the cameo
um i have a patreon account patreon.com
inside of you that's if you want to give
to the podcast a little bit more i'll
message you right after i really
appreciate it check out patreon.com
inside of you inside of you online store
has tons of merch uh thesunspin.com you
can zoom me and get merch there for the
band um
a lot of great stuff uh i will be
in
lexington kentucky this weekend doing a
smallville nights and a signing with tom
welling my co-star from smallville and
then on the 24th of september i'll be in
west virginia so get tickets to that
because that's that's gonna be a lot of
fun as well
um yeah a lot of good stuff going on man
uh
you know i've been writing a lot and um
like i said i've been i've been
exercising a little more trying i think
that does help me a little bit
i think so too i think you just have to
i mean if you're feeling something and
you don't like it go do something yeah
i gotta learn to meditate again man i
gotta get back into it i gotta start
doing things that
more therapy
more [ __ ] therapy ryan more therapy
and exercise for everybody yeah all
around you hear that it works for some
of us
maybe a little bit of music here and
there yeah little music music does help
i always have music playing in the house
not now because it would interrupt
uh let's get into the top tier patrons
we do it every week ryan has just been
killing it he just knows all the names
uh do you want to skip it this week
do whatever you want to do
all right
nancy d leah s tricia f these are
patrons that give a little extra and
they get the top tier and they get their
names read off sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill yukiko's back wasn't you
kiko gone for a minute
maybe not
jill e bryan h mama lauren g nico p
jerry w robert l jason w apothean
kristen k amelia o allison l raj c
joshua d emily s cj p
see the random ryan there random ryan
samantha m
jennifer n stacy l gen s jamal f janelle
b kimberly
oh uh e correct mike e l don sopremo 99
more amira santiago m sarah f chad w
liam p janine r ray hey gosh you're good
maya p maddie s shannon d matt w belinda
and kevin v james r chris h dave h
spider-man
chase sheila
g brad
d wow ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a
michelle k mish michael s talia m betsy
d
claire m laura l chad l rochelle nathan
e marion meg
c k damn janelle p travel dan n
uh
uh jeddah uh jeddah lorraine g kerry h
veronica k big stevie w kendall t
carol d
uh angel m rhiannon c yes corey
l okay close letter off
super
uh super sam good emily c coleman g dev
nixon michelle a liz l jeremy c andy t
cody r sebastian that's a tough one
i was going to say k again yes
holy [ __ ] gavinator nh david c elliott m
john b brandy d yvore camille s
bond
jovi
bono
the c
joey m p.t scarborough
pt scarborough and willie f you were my
top tier patrons i couldn't do the show
without you you give back
and i thank you from the bottom of my
heart
i hope you enjoyed the podcast today i
certainly did uh i'm michael rosenbaum
from the hollywood hills of california
old hills i brought tails
waving to that camera ryan as we always
do we love you thank you for allowing me
to be inside of each and every one of
you i appreciate you listening and
supporting the podcast all right
[Music]